[Música]
es una de las monarquías más antiguas de
europa pero hoy tambalea nombrado por el
difunto dictador francisco franco como
el próximo en la línea del trono de
español juan carlos primero fue durante
mucho tiempo respetado como el rey de la
transición democrática de españa y
considerado un símbolo de la
reconciliación del país tras el
franquismo pero hoy puede llegar a ser
la causa de la caída de la monarquía la
monarquía de españa ahora es sólo
apoyada por una minoría y en medio de
las polémicas una persona es clave su
última amante que tanto desean los
españoles que siga la monarquía en su
país nuestros reporteros salieron a las
calles de españa para conocer más sobre
sus sentimientos al respecto
[Música]
este verano en las calles de madrid el
republicanismo se moviliza
la consigna es clara
la convocamos desde la convicción de que
el futuro de este país es incompatible
con el futuro de la monarquía que no le
queda mucho tiempo
está más débil que nunca y que es el
momento de movilizarse contra contra la
moral
es el momento porque desde hace semanas
el descontento popular aumenta en pleno
confinamiento los españoles descubren en
la prensa nuevos escándalos financieros
ligados al droid y que es una vergüenza
que tenga que haber recortes y que haya
gente muriéndose de hambre y que el
corrupto de juan carlos primero y
seguramente el corrupto de su hijo
felipe sexto están robando a la gente
para rené otadui portavoz de una de las
principales asociaciones republicanas
toda la familia real es culpable tratan
de hacernos creer que es un problema de
una manzana podrida que está en un cesto
y que retirando esa manzana podrida pues
podrán dar continuidad a su reinado es
evidente que cada vez más frente opina
que ha llegado el momento de impulsar un
proceso republicano
y días más tarde rené participa en una
asamblea de asociaciones republicanas el
orden del día es la planificación de las
acciones futuras
de tal forma que esto no es un debate
académico
aquí tenemos hablar para concretar y
organizar un proyecto de lucha a favor
de la república
de la transición democrática de 1978
los republicanos recuerdan que juan
carlos fue designado por franco como su
sucesor para ellos su exilio es una
primera victoria y tiene que ir del país
bueno pues no sólo se va a ir
y al completo
el pasado 3 de agosto el rey emérito
sorprendió a los españoles con su exilio
a los emiratos árabes unidos
[Música]
el rey juan carlos ha comunicado a su
hijo el rey felipe sexto su intención de
abandonar españa el rey emérito dejará
de vivir en la zarzuela tras las
informaciones sobre su futura sports su
fortuna fuera de españa
[Música]
un exilio necesario para salvar la
monarquía como nos explica james batko
corresponsal del periódico británico the
telegraph
james reveló la existencia de la
fundación lúcuma basada en panamá cuyo
beneficiario era juan carlos pero
también su hijo el rey actual felipe
sexto
el hecho de que el rey felipe salen
nombrado en esta fundación pues causó un
pequeño terremoto y el mismo día que
salió en el dominical del télégraphe
esta tarde saca una comunicación de la
casa real de españa con después una
reacción muy contundente y bastante
inesperada que te pone en especie de
línea yo creo entre él y su padre
[Música]
felipe sexto dice ignorar la existencia
de la fundación y anuncia la renuncia a
su herencia por primera vez la corona
actual se ve directamente salpicada por
los escándalos del antiguo soberano
había un pacto con juan carlos
es como fundador del estado moderno
español
pero a la vez siempre se ha sabido que
tiene una relación quizás muy ligera con
el dinero pero llega un momento en que
esas cosas de afuera pues entran tienen
su influencia y claro dejando digamos en
descubierto pero para comprender por qué
la popularidad de la monarquía se ha
derrumbado
hay que volver ocho años atrás en 2012
en el peor momento de la crisis
económica mientras que uno de cada dos
jóvenes estaba en el paro el país
descubre esta foto
juan carlos posa delante de un elefante
al que ha matado en botsuana durante un
lujoso safari el viaje podría haber
quedado en secreto pero juan carlos se
rompe la cadera y es repatriado de
urgencia la foto ha quedado grabada en
la memoria colectiva de los españoles
horribles no me siento nada orgulloso de
verla y yo creo que ahí empieza un poco
el declive de la imagen de la casa real
aquí en españa
pues mira se me ponen los pelos de punta
sinceramente
no comprendo cómo este señor está a
estado de rey aquí en españa pero ya
sabíamos que los borbones aquí en españa
habían robado ya habían sido
sinvergüenzas siempre
los españoles están tan escandalizados
que a su salida del hospital por primera
vez el rey se excusó
mucho mejor agradezco a todo el equipo
médico y a la clínica en fin como
maltratados
estoy deseando tomar mis acciones
lo siento mucho lo hicimos cabo y no
volver a ocurrir
el soberano pierde entonces toda
credibilidad hasta tal punto que dos
años más tarde ante la sorpresa general
decide abdicar
he decidido poner fin a mi reinado y
abdicar la corona de españa pero la
historia no acaba de su pasado lo
persigue los escándalos financieros y
sentimentales de juan carlos
contribuyeron a su caída como recuerda
jaime peñafiel periodista cercano al rey
y en medio de los escándalos una persona
es clave su última amante
colina no fue la primera
y mucho menos ha sido la última
vivía a 300 metros en la casita que allí
todos había guardado del prometido que
se iba a casar con ella
y no se le comunica a sus hijos
expresiones divórciate
y después no se ha casado entonces todos
los que cuentan con el fruto del
despecho se han estrechado despechada es
un peligro
amante del rey durante años corina sabe
muchas cosas como lo muestra esta
conversación grabada en secreto por un
antiguo policía español nunca le dije al
rey vas a tomar comisiones de las
empresas españolas que han conseguido el
contrato del tren de estas pagado por el
gobierno español para representar estas
compañías no puedes tomar este dinero él
se enfadó y me contestó eres tan alemana
un regalo que correspondería a una
comisión asignada al rey por haber hecho
de intermediario entre españa y arabia
saudita en la concesión de las obras de
la línea del tren de alta velocidad
entre medina y la meca
ahora maine el ave del desierto
o las comisiones es un delito esa puede
ser la falta de ética
y entonces rociar las cosas sería
acusado de manejo económico mejor que
hasta con la autonomía de toda su vida
la boca el franco en 40 años de reinado
juan carlos ha cultivado una fortuna lo
afirma su antigua amante recientemente
entrevistada en hombres por un medio
español
72 65 millones de euros debe tener mucho
dinero
quizás mil millones de euros 2000
aquí es donde podemos citar lo que dijo
new york times' y forbes quienes
estimaron la fortuna del rey entre 1400
y 2300 millones de euros
en 2018 un fiscal de génova decide
indagar en las cuentas de juan carlos
depositadas en suiza y abre un proceso
por un supuesto delito de blanqueo de
capitales el pasado junio el tribunal
supremo español decide investigar
también las cuentas del antiguo monarca
por posible corrupción sin embargo
frente a todas estas acusaciones parte
de los españoles continúan apoyando la
institución pensamos que como ciudadanos
es un derecho y un deber defender este
sistema que funciona muy bien y que
queremos que permanezca porque garantiza
a todas nuestras libertades y derechos
atocha ha creado esta asociación
monárquica que hoy ya reúne cerca de
2.000 personas
que tal carlos tanto tiempo como estos
jóvenes que se toman personalmente la
defensa de juan carlos yo creo en la
presunción de inocencia que es un
derecho a nuestro estado y hasta que no
haya un juicio y hasta que no se le
declaró culpable no creo que se pueda
manchar en absoluto su trayectoria como
rey yo que sé el y os haya tenido lo que
sea a mí me afecta en absoluto también
lo que me afecta es lo que ha hecho por
nosotros lo que nos ha construido los
españoles y a toda la nación el tema de
los acuerdos comerciales beneficiosos
que ha conseguido para españa
el desarrollo y el impulso de todas
estas relaciones con países árabes
estos jóvenes españoles consideran ser
parte de una mayoría silenciosa como
javier un madrileño que en 1978 vivió la
transición democrática
es curioso porque hemos vivido 22
generaciones diferentes yo viví la
generación del comienzo de la democracia
donde para mí representa la lucha por la
democracia por la libertad por la
igualdad por la justicia por la
solidaridad y todo eso se plasma en la
constitución y sin embargo ahora la
nueva generación lo que ve son otros
valores como la unidad por lo que
estamos viviendo
marina de 13 años es finalista en el
concurso escolar de dibujo que es un rey
para ti organizado por la casa real
ahora mismo estoy represa representando
al rey uniendo españa'
por haciéndola para representar que
todos estamos unidos que no caben
[Música]
para marín a su padre la monarquía es
antes que todo un símbolo de unidad y de
estabilidad no entienden porque una
parte de la población desea su abolición
pero qué parte ante la inacción del
centro de investigaciones sociológicas
una agrupación de 16 medios de
comunicación independientes se ha
decidido a preguntar a los españoles
estos son los profesores de la
universidad que lideran la encuesta
una muestra representativa de 3.000
personas cuestionada por un instituto de
sondaje es la mayor encuesta que se ha
hecho sobre monarquía en desde que
existe la democracia en españa desde el
año 78 y que nos va a permitir saber
todas las claves y todas las y cruzar
todas las variables de cuál de cuál es
el sentimiento de la gente de españa
hacia laborar kia y hacia la república
también veredicto el 41% de los
españoles estaría a favor de una
república contra el 35 por ciento que
prefiere la monarquía una situación
inédita en la historia reciente del país
sin embargo la familia real dispone de
una clara ventaja la mayoría de las
fuerzas políticas apoya a la monarquía
la forma de estado en españa está muy
clara artículo 1 de la constitución
española españa es un estado social
democrático y de derecho de una
monarquía parlamentaria pero yo no creo
que la monarquía como institución esté
en riesgo más allá de que hay un partido
que intenta continuamente golpearle y
ponerla a riesgo
este partido sería podemos el partido de
izquierda radical presente en la
coalición del gobierno de as
pues bien aquí estamos
gloria él hizo es una de las pocas
diputadas que se expresa abiertamente
sobre la cuestión existe una visión
clara de cuál es el régimen
constitucional el blindaje incluso en la
propia constitución de cuál es el modelo
de estado es muy privilegiado está
prácticamente blindado y llegaría hasta
el punto de la reforma constitucional
del modelo de estado español que
implicaría la disolución de las cortes a
mí me parece imagen inimaginable que una
cuestión tan importante estemos en una
situación tan complicada
[Música]
la llegada de la tercera república
española es incierta
sin embargo tras estos más de 40 años en
la jefatura del estado
la monarquía nunca ha estado tan
debilitada
hoy está en las manos de felipe sexto el
futuro de la dinastía de los borbones
[Aplausos]
[Música]
hasta aquí el boleto de vuelta a la
monarquía española si desea ver
nuevamente este reportaje lo invitamos a
visitar france24 puntocom
y